[Music]
so uh please welcome Rafael he will talk
about writing code you won't hate
tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
Bonjour that's about as much French as I
can do without insulting all of you good
I got someone someone over the crowd
all right cool so I think you know he's
it's a good dog explaining to us talking
a lot about the the work we do in terms
of delivering value and I think that's
really important for us as well and I
think there's a kind of second side to
side so I like I like how these two
talks are gonna complement each other
because I want to talk about another
problem that you know we developers face
on a day-to-day basis
and that is the problem of looking at
the code we wrote yesterday I mean how
many of you open up an old repository
for someone else or some code you saw
from someone else and react like this oh
my god that I really write that did I do
that
all right how many of you feel like that
I mean if you're not being honest with
you secure yourself cool or maybe you
know it's not your code is someone
else's code and you're like why why do
we do this right that's why we hate
legacy code we look at this code it's
like why did people make these decisions
why is it fighting against me every time
I try to do something and then we have
that urge of just simply needing to
rewrite all of it
right how many of you feel like this is
your job actually rewriting code as is
that's just what is right and that's
simple because we as developers we
believe we can do better we always
believe we can do better than we did
yesterday we always believe we can
better than everyone else that's fine
it's part of being a creative you know
you believe you have a new approach you
believe have a new way now there's one
other problem with that and that's the
saying that bounces around the internet
constantly which is that real developers
ship stuff
that's great shipping stuff is really
important we learned all about
delivering value and I think if if we
don't deliver value then what are we
doing because at least in my world
clients don't pay unless you deliver
does anyone get paid without delivering
okay good I'm doing something right then
and at the end of the day we have to
balance that how do we how do we figure
it out now just delivering is not enough
just delivering is not gonna cut it let
me tell you a little story about that so
if we look at this is the Tacoma Narrows
Bridge in Seattle in the US and it was
built around November of 1940 so they
needed to get across the river they
built a bridge the project was quick the
project was actually executed in a
really good time and it was delivered so
they shipped it they actually shipped it
all right
so imagine this is your website you have
just delivered your website and that's
great people are getting across
however just four months after that the
winds in the area picked up slightly so
imagine you getting a little bit more of
an influx of clients to your system now
you know more people coming in your
system is starting to react weird you
looking at the logs something is off and
it keeps getting worse now I went
engineer imagine this is your website so
a pretty chef brigeth should not be
doing that and I don't think you would
want your website to do the same and
imagine this is where your alerts start
going off and here everyone's getting
paid to do the pages all the emails
you're getting all calling them it's
probably not good you probably don't
want this right and that's the thing
this bridge lasted all of four months
four months can you imagine how long it
took to brill building a bridge the
amount of effort that goes into that in
four months because you probably forgot
the calculation about you know resonance
which is the case for this bridge and
that happens can you imagine putting the
same effort into your website and then a
week later you're like well this was
great I'm gonna rewrite it now we can't
keep doing that so we need to find
balance and if that doesn't give you
enough motivation to find the balance
there were no victims of that bridge
except for a dog so you know killing a
dog doesn't sound like a good way to
start just say so how do we find that
balance how do we find a balance between
delivering keeping the quality up and
still you know being able to keep code
that you will not have to keep rewriting
over and over so I believe and I've
looked over much of these projects after
I figure out why is it why is it that we
resist our old code so much why is it
that we feel that code goes bad right
code code is like perishable if you if
you leave lettuce out too long it gets
black and horrible you don't want to eat
it and the same thing happens with code
if you just leave it there and you look
at it again it's like oh wow this
doesn't look good why is that and if you
go look at all these reasons a big part
of it is evolution everything around us
evolves the language we're using the
framework we're using and you all of
these things evolve you learn new things
I mean to be fair if you don't hate the
code you did yesterday you probably
haven't learned anything new and that's
also bad for you right I actually feel
good when I look at my own code I say
look this is horrible I can do better I
have learned to do better and that's
really good you know focus on that so
all of these changes all it is evolution
makes you feel you know that way about
the old code you have the other thing
that really doesn't help this process is
complexity complexity really kills
comprehension the more complex something
is the harder it is for someone else to
understand it right we just saw here
from the TLDR like documentation is a
big part of that if you can't understand
what's happening how else are you gonna
work with that code unless you start you
know taking it apart and replacing it
and rewriting it sometimes we just fall
prey to bad design we started off with a
wrong idea the client changed their mind
I mean clients never changed their mind
right that never happens we have to deal
with these things how do we deal with
this constant barrage
of baggage and then finally we have NIH
does anyone know what the NIH is
screaming out not invented here the
German art of saying no to everything
else they have and that's the idea you
you're looking is like well you know
someone else did this I can do it better
why should I use someone else's code why
should I use something someone else did
because I can do it better this was not
invented by us let's go do something
else if you've seen any talks here and
at least free talks yesterday already
mentioned this open source is the core
of our industry if you're not doing open
source you're burning through money
that's it we're supposed to be building
on the shoulders of giants right so the
other thing that you really see is
change like if you look at all of these
things that affect and make you not like
your old code it's all about change we
have a real we know we have to deal with
change constantly whether it's the the
market we're in whether it's the product
you're building whether it's the
language you're using things change
constantly that is the one constant I
can guarantee you will find wherever you
go in your careers of the developer
change change change
so can we solve this problem this
anxiety of our old code and dealing with
change how can we do that now I wish I
could stand here and you know take on a
preachers voice and tell you I have
found the solution to all of this the
reality is there is no solution there is
no silver bullet
if anyone sells you a silver bullet you
no doubt it because there is no one way
if there was one way to fix all of our
problems this would be a really short
conference but no we have what five six
tracks how many speakers do we have
around that's because there's so many
different ways that we can solve
problems but going back to that one
constant that one constant is change so
how do you deal with that constant of
change you need to prepare your code to
be replaced that is the reality code
will be replaced constantly
now this can be a simple process you
know if you look at the TDD cycle
refactor refactoring is part of the
process it's quick it doesn't have an
impact on the overall delivery right or
it can be a really painful process where
you know for every feature you want to
implement you need twice the time to
prepare the code to receive that feature
that's not good that's gonna slow you
down you don't want that so you need to
make sure your code is easy to replace
that's the only way you can deal with
all these problems making yourself
adaptable to change so what does that
mean well it can mean all the way from
making the code easy to understand
readability making sure whoever works
with it next understand why it's there
how to work with it make it more
flexible again dealing with change if
you can easily make a change to the code
you're probably going to do it and
you're gonna have no problems if you
can't easily make a change to the code
you're probably gonna struggle you're
gonna complain and that's not gonna go
well either for you or for the people
work with you more than that make sure
the code is tested testing is the basis
of confidence make it easy to change
replace refactor right that's our TDD
cycle refactoring constantly
green red refactor and finally and if I
can give you one silver bullet and that
one you can trust is the only way to
make sure that you're never gonna have
problems if that code is to make it not
exist that's it that's the only real way
of not having problems of your code and
it is achievable it's simple start using
or someone else's code right so allow me
to give you a couple of examples of
ideas that you might want to pursue that
might help you in this line of making
code more flexible and I'll give you a
couple of general ideas and focus on one
specific one so first of all testing
right testing is key to all this please
if as if you saw a Larry stock yesterday
automated testing has been around since
1975 what is your excuse for not doing
automated testing it right and that's it
if you're doing refactoring if you're
constantly changing your code and you
don't have tests it's like playing Jenga
now Jenga is fun when you have
beer in your hand at the end of the
conference not so much when you're doing
every day at the office so you don't
want to you want to avoid that following
simple ideas simple concepts concepts
like solid and stupid simple things
single responsibility open and close
principle disco I'm not going to go into
details but we all know this we've heard
this this isn't all the talks we go
around so look into these what do they
mean to do what what do they mean to you
what do they mean to your code try and
absorb those those concepts module
architectures we've seen the rise or the
the re rise of all of these different
concepts CQRS event sourcing all of
these architectures that pro-x angular
architectures we've had at least two
talks already in this conference they're
all there to give you that flexibility a
street programming I come from PHP so
I'm come from a land where strict
programming is not the default strong
typing is not the default but now we
have that option I mean most of you
working with Java Ruby you have that
option and strict programming well it
sounds like that nagging thing that your
friend coder always tells you to do it
actually does make a big difference it
allows you to tell the code what to
expect it allows you to avoid a lot of
the pitfalls that we have to deal with
on a day to day basis oh is this really
a string right I mean we're very we need
to question our code at every turn when
you start working with more strict
programming type hints and final classes
you start controlling the life cycle of
that code a lot better you start being
able to communicate with the code what
you expect to happen in the future so
hey I don't expect you to extend this
class I expect you to use this public
interface please send me a string not
something that looks like one so that
really helps you communicate and kill
that complexity we were talking about
right you're reducing the complexity of
your code
increasing your comprehension pie I mean
who doesn't love pie right it's the
opposite of NIH proudly invented here
right it's probably vented elsewhere
here we go
put your thinking myself now but that's
the idea right instead of you know we're
having to build everything yourself Oh
source come on everything has a good
package manager' nowadays HP has
Composer ruby has bundler - has
something we forgot the name
we all have PIP area we all have great
package managers we all have a way of
using code that is out there
battle-tested
worked on by millions of people why not
draw from that source why why not just
keep doing that I mean it really helps
you move along and not have to deal with
you know having to write every single
piece of code maybe don't go so far as
left pad but you get the idea
the other thing is readability right if
we look at writing code it is not very
different from writing text and I
guarantee when you write a text to
someone except if it's on like whatsapp
or telegram you worry about punctuation
you worry about paragraphs right if
you're writing a book if you're writing
a report I guarantee you take care of
how you format that text because that is
gonna change how people are going to
understand what you're saying
same thing goes for code you know you
can separate logic blocks with white
space yes white space white space is
good turns out you know there's many
different ways that you can use code
styles and in different structures to be
able to communicate easier through that
code so readability in code is also a
thing look into that figure out what
what you find readable and start
understanding especially how the brain
works
right because at the end of the day a
colder going through a piece of code is
exactly the same thing as the machine
with a parser going through it the only
thing is we only have one core it
doesn't have that much memory right so
you kind of want to be a little bit
easier on the brain so in trying to
figure this out and then trying to see
how how to not regret everything I keep
doing I stumbled into something really
incredible to me that at least changed
how I work with things and it's called
object aesthetics it was part of an
essay written by Jeff Bay for the Fort
Worth's ontology has anyone ever heard
of it no Wow cool
prepare to be blown away no I hope so
the idea is so so Jeff wrote this for
the photo anthology and the word
calisthenics means exercises right so
it's small repetitious exercises that
you do over and over to achieve a bigger
goal it's like going to the gym and
lifting weights you're constantly
exercising that muscle to then have a
bigger goal at the end it's the same
idea here these are nine exercises and
care for the word exercise it not rules
this is not something that you should
follow strictly this is not something
that you should not violate these are
exercises and by repeating these
exercises over and over thinking of
things slightly different it has an
impact on your overall thinking now this
is focused on object oriented it was
originally written for Java we
successfully ported it into PHP and
started using it and saw really good
improvements over the years with PHP 7
and all the advances we've had in there
we've actually been able to go closer
back to the origin of of the
calisthenics and follow the same rules
that's how far PHP has come which is
really cool so keep in mind these are
exercises do them and a side project do
them for work I don't care just find a
place and just try them out for a bit
so I'm gonna go over some of these I
won't go into too much detail but you
can always talk to me afterwards if you
want I have a longer version of this
that we can talk about so the first rule
is only used one level of annotation per
method it's like what what does that
have to do with quality software well it
turns out that with one level of
indentation only in your method
you only have a limit of how much you
can do remember when you try to put a
for each inside a for each yeah that's
already two levels of indentation so you
can do that right so it may sound silly
but if you keep trying to write softer
and you keep trying to follow this rule
you will notice that you will extract
methods way more often than you would
before you start separating making sure
that that method is doing one thing
remember the S from solid single
responsibility making sure that method
does one thing and there's one thing
very well
I mean just right pick up an open-source
code or something that you maintain and
just go through your methods and try to
make sure they only have one level of
annotation compare the results and then
you tell me if it's more readable or not
rule number two and please don't throw
anything yet don't use the word else now
I have nothing against the word else
that's not the problem but we all know
that Forks indecision in code increased
the cyclomatic complexity of code it
also increases the amount of brainpower
you need to understand what's going on
of that code so if you flip your else's
let's say you have an if-else so if
something is bigger than six do this
else do that the thing that you're
probably looking for in most of these
methods is your method does one thing so
if you have a method called create post
and you have an if-else that checks if
the post is valid or not you're you're
interested about creating the post
that's what the method does so if you
start flipping your else's removing them
and replacing them with if you know
contrary ifs what you end up with is
instead of having this tree of decisions
you have a nice exit strategy so all
those ifs become breakpoints the things
that will stop this method from doing
what it should be doing so if I say if
this post is invalid throw an exception
that interrupts the method if this post
is already existing the database
returned early if I take away all these
if so I take out all of the data if in
the beginning of the code I will see
exactly what that baffle was supposed to
do oh this is how you create a post and
these are the break points that stop me
from doing that now some people are not
big fans of early returns that's fine
exceptions are still also a good
solution for this and I find that if you
come into a code and you're able to look
at this and browse through this backbone
of the method and see okay this is
what's gonna stop me and this is what
I'm supposed to do it's a lot easier to
understand that so getting rid of elseís
does help a little bit with that number
three wrapping primitive types and
actually you can even this
behavior just rap the primitive types
especially if you're doing something
like Java where you know that doesn't
have any implications don't remember
anything
and the thing is this really helps you
communicate so for example if you take
code like this repaint false like if
you're looking at this call you have no
idea what false means should i repaint
but not repaint what does it mean you
have to go back to the origin of the
method to understand what is being said
now if I replace this with an object
wrapping that false now you understand
oh ok
I'm trying to repaint but not animate
while I'm doing it all right so it's a
simple thing but you can start it can be
the beginning of something bigger
because now as you start looking at the
original method it was repainting and
animating which is again violating the
single responsibility now you can start
putting all of the behavior regarding
animation into that one method into that
object the animate object so you can
start segmenting data more and more and
there's numerous examples of this out
there if you look at libraries like
money money libraries like money
handling libraries they do all of that
transforming of data in the backend so
you don't have to worry about it and you
have a simple interface to talk to
so you're wrapping what is a float in an
object so try not only one arrow per
line replace this with dot if you're a
Java developer but essentially it's you
know Demeter's law right you don't want
to be looking into the result of the
result of the result of the result
because somewhere in the middle there
something might be no and everything
blows up and it doesn't go well all
right so this is the idea of only
interacting with your direct neighbors
not going deeper into understanding
because now if there's a change in that
second call you're making how many
places are you gonna have to go back to
and change how you're dealing with that
number five do not abbreviate now we
feel really smart when we abbreviate
stuff I know you do I know you do I do
too
right but then you wake up the next
morning
and maybe you don't feel so smart I mean
if you look at this code I'm pretty sure
it meant something to whoever wrote it
but right now they can't even explain to
me what it is I mean what is that sy and
why New York what is it
right but hey I guarantee you the first
time you write this
I feel good look at that I expressed all
of that complexity in two letters and I
can never understand what it means again
so abbreviation is is is a relic from
the past back when we used to code on
notepad and had to write all these
variables down I mean your IDs whatever
you use they're probably gonna give you
type hinting on the on the variables are
you really gaining anything by making a
variable that's two letters as opposed
to 15 are you probably not
number six keep your classes small now
what we mean by small varies a little
bit from language to language but in
general every class should have about
ten methods every method should have
about ten lines which means every class
was about a hundred lines that's small
it's focused again you're gonna have a
lot of classes but you will have classes
that are very easy to test they're very
easy to mock very easy to replace and
very easy to refactor and that's the
goal you're trying to keep up at the end
number seven limiting your instance
variables to two so an instance variable
is when you pass an object to an object
and it gets saved into a property so
when you create your controllers and you
inject all these things into the
controller for example only inject two
things now the idea here is the more
things you inject into the class first
of all testing is going to become a pain
because you're probably gonna want to
mock all of these things and then you're
gonna start mocking everything and then
you have 15 marks to be able to run one
little method that's not fun that's not
how testing is supposed to go so the
last thing is you're injecting they're
easier it's going to be the test also it
gets you thinking and that's the rule
that's the idea behind all of these
ideas right is to get you thinking a
little bit more are all these things
necessary for the critical path of my
method can i delay it can I use an event
based system to
triggered these actions elsewhere do I
actually need this one class to call
everything do I need the god class to be
talking to everything so think about
that using first class collections and
this really helps you just handle data
instead of being worried about oh this
is a collection of apples or a
collection of oranges you can have a
collection that has both you get all of
the benefits of collections of filtering
and whatnot and if you have good
object-oriented design behind that it's
easy enough to pull out okay I just need
the oranges I just need the apples do
this with the Apple do that with the
orange so you put that outside
everything and finally don't use getters
and setters okay no one threw anything
that's good and it's like well why are
we complaining about getters and setters
now right it's like tabs and spaces why
are we doing this but the idea is it's
not don't use them and then they're evil
it's more about what can you do that's
not just together and setter because if
you go look at a getter and a setter
they're very generic what do they mean
oh it means get it mean set can I do
better
well maybe you can maybe instead of
using your getter and setter you can
have more of a domain driven approach to
it so for example if you if you're
coding a game and in that game you
collect a coin instead of having the
coin say set your score to one maybe you
know let the score actually control that
and say here I collected a coin what
does it mean to the score oh it means I
should add one right or you can have
more you know you can do a lot more
immutability making sure your objects
are consistent as they go along but
essentially you're communicating better
what the interface of that object is
what you can do with it right so I urge
you try this try it for a month just
pick up a side project pick up something
small at the office doesn't matter open
source or maybe just take some of your
code and refactor it trying to follow
these exercises but just give it a go
just try it as an exercise it's not you
know the end of the world please don't
put this into your your beach be storm
inspection checkers don't don't do this
as a coding style some people have its
it's insane don't have arguments why did
you have more than one level of
indentation sometimes you need it
sometimes you need to break all of these
rules sometimes you need to do them all
at once that's fine but just by trying
this and forcing yourself to think every
time you make one of these choices you
will notice that you'll start thinking
more about the big picture of the code
now I started doing this eight years ago
and and I've really have not written an
L since then it's a lie I probably wrote
a couple of them but it did change how I
think it did change how I look at the
big picture right having smaller simpler
parts of code makes it so much easier to
deal with that code so here you are at
kung fu so much to learn so many new
topics and I will repeat what you said
already earlier just make sure you take
all of this information go back home and
figure out what it means to you right
everyone who's on stage here is showing
you a path it's not the D path it's a
path it may work for me it may work for
someone else it may not work for you but
that's why you're here get inspired look
at everything your look you're learning
internalize it and find what works for
you thank you very much
[Music]